welcome to the across the spoilerverse
podcast I'm your host Bond James Bond
joined by my man Greg Alba as per usual
how's it going Greg we need some
positivity to start the podcast with oh
it's going great Paul uh Bond Pub bomb
you said you were James Bond I was half
listening to you and your your intro was
getting distracted by something on my
computer uh but no it's going good it's
going to be a good month movies will
rebound movies will rebound don't worry
Paul because we got some topics to talk
about today on the agenda ladies and
gentlemen if you're watching this on
YouTube please leave a like on this
video but you could also catch us of
course on uh Apple Spotify wherever you
get podcasts listen
um Superman super I'm learning to speak
today Superman Legacy casting we gotta
talk about Indiana Jones bombing as
expected and then um some movies that
are coming out this month where it looks
like they're acting well and some are
looking to be future bombs as well and
of course yet again another Jonathan
Majors update but Paul I think we should
start off I I have not I haven't even
really shared my opinion about the
Superman Legacy casting because it's
really short I haven't heard Europe we
haven't even talked in private about the
Superman legacy cast and you just you
just messaged me going you're gonna do
it I'm like yeah I'm putting koi on it
but I I actually haven't even gotten
your I've gotten your opinion about the
way the movement went to getting
Superman in here and all that
um and of course how it didn't seem like
the smart move to fire Henry Cavill and
yada yada yada but what do you think
about David is corn sweat what a
fascinating name David Corin sweat as
Clark Kent Superman and Rachel brossahan
as Lois Lane
I'm happy I will say that I'm quite
happy you know when it got announced the
DC fandom yeah we're always very divided
you go on any anywhere talking about a
DC movie someone's gonna argue with you
um and it just felt for that moment when
the casting was announced that you know
a lot of people came together put the
differences to the side and thought I'm
hopeful about the future you know when
we made this podcast Greg what we wanted
to do was make something positive for
people to listen to feel like they're
just hanging out with us listening to
our opinions it's not too deep it's not
too serious we're not caught We're not
gonna go crazy and go on big rants about
how much we hate everything and how
everything's been ruined but the last
couple of weeks yeah we've just seemed
to have hit a point where the topics
every single week are very negative
results and unfortunately it's probably
gonna be that for the rest of this
episode as well but we were seeing this
it was like finally something nice and
hopeful for the future that we can get
excited for and I I think the casting's
great
um I haven't really seen David Curran
sweating much I saw him in Hollywood
when it was on I think it was called
Hollywood on Netflix where it was set in
the early days of Hollywood and it was
about
um the Oscars and stuff like that and he
it was like try it was basically an
actor trying to make his way in the
Tinseltown and he worked at some garage
and then just worked his way into movies
and that that was basically it had lots
of different characters in it but he was
really good in it
um I haven't seen Pearl or X
unfortunately but I've heard he's he's
quite good in those he's in one of them
at least
um but yeah excited to see it you know
he looks the part I know people are
saying that he's kind of Henry Cavill Jr
um and they're saying he's not in shape
he's not muscly but Henry Cavill wasn't
to be fair and yeah I'm just you know
give the guy a chance please guys and so
I was as annoyed as anyone over the
whole Henry Cavill thing I was ringing
Greg about three in the morning going
I'm gonna kill someone like shut up just
give the guy a chance
so yeah what did you think Greg I
um I'm just kind of like yeah this
sounds fine to me yeah I'm not I'm not
over the moon about it nor am I negative
about it you know what I mean like it's
the right kind of casting he he
generally had like his face looks the
part we know actors can bulk up when
they're paid a lot of money except for
the guy who plays no more anyone else
has the capability of buffing up to play
a character especially like Superman and
they they know they just have to
um and I like the idea that we're
following the tradition of a
generally unknown gentleman because that
is the best way I think to just see
Superman and you know be able to see
ourselves within Superman to some extent
you know James Gunn's been testing I
mean I don't know how many people he's
been testing but he's taking this role
more serious than anything else like he
knows the there's a lot a lot of
pressure on this movie and he has to get
it right so I I TR if there's one thing
with James Gunn he rarely goes wrong
with casting I I can't really
think of a role where like
man that was totally miscast in a movie
of his uh he usually has such a big
Ensemble he still manages to like hit
the nail on the head every single time
so I imagine that there's something
special about this guy I mean a lot of
times when it comes to casting for these
Legacy characters the first thing we
look at is what do they look like in the
week we care so much more about their
physical appearance right up front he
looks fine for that uh at the same time
I'm excited to see what he does a lot of
people I don't know any of these actors
honestly like Rachel Ross I don't know
what she's done Miss maisel okay yeah I
haven't seen that it's too non-american
for my brain Paul
is American is it which one's that show
I thought that was the British show
you know it's the Amazon show about this
and that's it and the guy from Men In
Black who gets his head blown off and
then it grows back you know in the city
I think that's the dad
um
what's the Phoebe Waller Bridge show
yeah I always thought that um
okay I've got in my shows way confused
either way I don't if I'm not reacting
to it I'm watching Vanderpump Rules so
you know I I don't I don't watch
television that sounds time that day I
didn't like your comments about the guy
who played Nemo Namo I thought he would
look I'm gonna look in the mirror now
and think oh I'm a bit out of shape I
look worse than him but um
but everyone seemed to about it
for some reason so yeah I guess I'm
supporting him and he's been canceled
plutio
a side note I was in a it was for the
flash at a screening for The Flash and I
heard a bunch of it was it was a bunch
of uh people who work in animation and
Comics who were in the row but I won't
say any any names but they were bitching
so loudly randomly about no more and wow
he didn't buff up for the role and these
are like
because they were talking about this
guy's weight I'm just going to say like
they were like super fat dudes they were
just like complaining their asses up
about no more is so funny to me
um but they were very they were
bohemianally serious about it and uh
that's what was in my Noggin right now
um but I used to stand it at the moment
to be fair you do have to kind of bulk
up as much as possible another thing
that guy can do it it looks like the
kind of guy who could get in good shape
don't quote me on that but he's he's
starting off from a good point you know
he's he's probably in quite good shape
already a huge Ackerman in the first
X-Men movie yet you remember
it was in pretty good shape but then guy
takes it the next level come come some
of the movies
um but obviously these two actors as
well the things they've started in our
period pieces which I think is quite an
interesting choice because I kind of
feel like James James Gunn my man James
Gunn he is sort of leaning in and maybe
hinting to us that he's going with that
so of
sentimental Superman if that makes sense
like the the old school type of golden
age Superman where it's very he's
basically Captain America with
superpowers you know what I mean his
attitude sort of classic American
um Farm Boy and you know to have these
two actors who are are from these period
pieces not I mean I think that both of
them are set in the 1950s I haven't
watched Miss maisel
um I walked in on my wife watching it a
couple of times and I was like what the
hell is this get this off I want to
watch Vanderpump or whatever the hell
was he said before crap crap joke but um
yeah so so it is quite interesting that
he's went with these two now there are
rumors that Lex Luthor
they're kind of going back and forth
between the scores God Brothers
um you've got the younger one which his
name's just disappeared
Alexander yeah yeah so that's quite
interesting that they're like we need a
scars God which one get them all in get
audition them all
I think
didn't that happen with the Hemsworth
brothers when it came to Thor all right
yeah I don't know but um Liam hems who
not Liam Hemsworth was it Luke Hemsworth
played Thor in Thor Ragnarok for the
play yeah yeah maybe something like that
but yeah that so yeah they've got the
the two guys in apparently
um I quite like Alexander skars God he
was in my favorite film of the so4
infinity pool really enjoyed that I
think the guy can do it he's sort of
older I feel like Lex Luthor needs to be
older you know I think he needs to be
more sort of a more scheming and
manipulative character who's sort of the
CEO of something whereas you know people
like the Jesse well some people like the
Jesse Eisenberg take
um I personally didn't buy with it that
much I prefer like a more mature Lex
Luthor
um so yeah that was that's kind of what
I'm looking for and I can see that more
on Alex than I can see it in bill the
bill is he's played a bold clown before
but Bill was also in John Wick
Continental which in some ways
chapter four uh which in some ways is
other than the accent you know you can
hearken that to Alex lutherish type uh
in in that movie he's in a suit and he's
fancy and he's rich and he's evil so you
know that's how you do
are you trying to do it
how you do everything it's how you do
how you do anything is how you do
everything it says that and it sounded
really bad when you feel like you have a
condition it's not that's what that's
how he's translating as a French accent
yeah no that's what I mean that's what
I'm saying uh so yeah he I think you
know either either one of them is gonna
be good I think yeah to be honest with
you great actors both of them are even
stellen Skarsgard can pull it off if you
wanted to but yeah I think I'm I'm with
you I would personally prefer you know
because Bill scars are like always
playing bad guys and even though I scan
Alexander skarsgard's played his fair
share a role of bad guys uh I I think it
would be cool to get Alex who does you
know have more of that
you know charismatic charm to him and
that physical build it'd be cool to get
Alex who actually looks physically
capable as well especially to one day
you know be wearing that big green suit
or whatever that he's got going on but
yeah Superman Legacy looking good we're
talking about actors getting in shape
you know who looks good for his age
still with his body you see him
shirtless at one point Indiana Jones
Harrison Ford yet yet his that that
Marvel body shot that he has in there it
wasn't enough to draw in the audiences
this movie Indiana Jones and the dial of
Destiny you just did a whole video on it
I have not listened to your video or
watched it so I don't really know what
you said but I imagine some of those
points will be reiterated here uh it is
open to what just 60 million dollars
yeah 130 million worldwide
um
disappointment it's like almost 300
million the budget right
well that's what Disney have said the
budget is but there's actually people
who've gone and worked things out and
they think due to the well most of it
was filmed in Europe and England so
they've worked out like the exchange
rates and they roughly say about 339
million
um so it's a lot of money
I feel sad seeing this happen you know
we have been kind of predicting this
would happen if you've been listening to
the podcast for a while we did put this
as being a box office bomb but
seeing it happen it just sucks because I
know for a fact it won't be the people
up top who get affected by this it'll
always be the people lower down like if
you've ever worked in a job where you
know profits have started dwindling they
don't get rid of the manager they get
rid of like the minimum wage workers or
the people who they don't really value
in the company and that'll be who gets
affected now Kathleen Kennedy's contract
Runs Out 2024
I feel like they're gonna just keep her
on and just slowly Shuffle her out the
door not really give her any new
projects to start on I'm not sure what's
going to happen with her Star Wars movie
but you know we're not Kathleen Kennedy
Hayes even though I brought that up as a
point today I was saying like there's a
lot of people against Kathleen Kennedy
and it doesn't always help with the box
office and I had so many comments saying
you're bloody in cell you you hate women
and you call Kathleen Kennedy out and
I'm like I don't but
I'm just saying it's a factor to some
people and it is if you go on YouTube
anywhere that there will probably be a
video about her ruining everything and
so you know that even if that's a small
amount it's still going to chip away
from the box office and basically what
my whole point of the video was it's not
one factor that has led to this
underperforming there's a lot of
different things going on here
um firstly is the fact they overspent on
it
if they'd done it for 150 million it
would be at a point now where it had
nearly made its money back green
lighting a 300 million dollar movie uh
on Indiana Jones is absolutely insane I
don't so so what they've done there is
they've either spent under delivered
um there's so many different reasons I
mean we can sit here and Bash the movie
all day it was fine you know there's a
lot of people who say it's one of the
worst things I've ever seen
and I I thought it was okay but there's
a lot of things that you know you're not
going into it thinking oh I'm gonna
spread so much word of mouth about how
good this movie is it's not across the
spider-verse where you come out it's not
top gun Maverick you know what I mean
where where you feel good at the end of
it and I think there's just so many
different issues with this film
um it wasn't marketed that well with the
the whole thing at Cairns and that
created a bad Buzz around its official
release because the early reviews were
very bad and
then you've got things like the the the
general like the the economy right now
we're in a cost of living crisis
film tickets are very very expensive now
if you want to take a whole family out
it costs a lot and I think that
audiences in general are kind of just
I said in the video basically they have
this mind state of fumi one shame on me
fool me twice shame on you and you know
audiences they've seen this happen with
lucasfilm over and over again where they
get excited about a movie they're
bringing old characters back and the way
they handle them isn't the best and you
know if you if you watch this movie they
take away from Indie more than they give
to him it's very sort of depressing you
know we will be spoiling it yeah just
heads up so if you don't want to know
any spoilers then leave
five four three two one so we find out
in the movie that his son died going off
to Vietnam you know that's horrendous
he's retiring he's divorced it's just
kind of
depressing and you feel like why have we
went back to this character to tell this
downtrodden story about like how how sad
he is and even things like Antonio
Banderas being killed Phoebe while
abridges are like yeah we made it out we
escaped um we did it and he's just like
my friend just died and there's just
constantly moments like that where it's
really sad you know there's people
getting killed that he works with for no
reason
um and even the ending of it just feels
kind of like it's not something you'd go
home and tell your friends about like
you must see this like if you think
about it top gun Maverick yeah
the the crash the Jet Tom Cruise and
whatever Tom Cruise and rooster they
crash the jet they're then gonna make it
out they're they're flying off there
they're fighting against these fifth
generation Jets everything's going down
how they gonna get out of here they hit
a point where it's like oh my God
there's a one more fifth generation Jet
and we've got no weapons left
oh no we're gonna we're going out and
then the the fifth generation jet what
does it do it drops a missile but then
boom hangman comes and he saves a day
it's like you've got a big cheer moment
I thought yeah that the Final Act of
this movie especially when we're going
into it it's back in time
I thought this is going to be like the
final stand of Indiana Jones it's going
to be the last hurray the final big
send-off
he's going to really show people that
he's still got it you can keep with it
you know he might be old but he's not
obsolete stuff's about to go down and
we're gonna see some classic scenes in
the past with Indiana Jones and what
they do instead is they have them
basically parachute down he gives a very
sad speech and he gets punched and
knocked out and then they cut to Black
and it's just kind of like how do you go
home and rant and Rave about that final
act in the way that you would something
like top gun Maverick where
like even talking about top gun Maverick
now and getting Goosebumps thinking
about hangman coming in to save the day
that final escape and Goosebumps goose
yeah
I had to I had to interrupt your flow to
point that's okay the goose please
continue I'm sorry yeah it's just kind
of like how do you go home and feel good
about that even like Harrison Ford's
done it in the past you know Luke's
heading towards a death star trench it's
all about to go down oh no Darth Vader
shows up he's got him in his sight he's
gonna kill him boom Millennium Falcon
comes in saves the day yeah yeah
and it didn't really have that moment in
the finale and for some reason they just
cut to Black and they don't even give
you like what they what have be would
have been the most obvious thing which
is she just talks Indie out of of like
wanting to stay in the past and she says
look Marion's waiting for you back home
come on please come with us you can see
this is showing you that everyone gets a
second chance and you know they climb
back on the plane they're flying out are
they gonna make it out the tear in time
oh it's closing it's closing they just
make it through just in time and you get
like oh yeah he's back he's he's went
through all that he's got his mind State
fixed he wants to be back with Mary and
they've just had an Amazing Escape from
the past but instead he wakes up kind of
sits about his room and then Marion
comes in like you didn't have anything
in the fridge
and it just feels very like downtrodden
for for a final Indiana Jones film you
know what I mean
first especially for us how good that
like some of the final acts of Indiana
Jones films have been it just kind of it
doesn't feel like this sort of film that
you want to go home and talk to people
about how good it made you feel and why
it was so so worth coming back I was
thinking today yeah I'll let you go next
don't worry about it but we've got
enough films now to make a final Indiana
Jones trilogy
um because we've got three final Indiana
Jones films now which is the Last
Crusade
the Crystal's got another dial of
Destiny so we've got three final Indiana
Jones films yeah
there are three endings huh
I agree I agree with you because
when I one thing I was loving about that
and I brought it up like in one of our
episodes is loving how the beginning I
love the beginning of this movie a lot
um specifically the moon Day stuff I was
cool with cranky old jaded Indie it felt
real where it seemed like the movie was
going was that you know especially when
he's talking with Salah and so I was
like I missed the days of sand and all
that that it was going to pull something
out of Indy where he finds that
adventurous Spirit again and that
excitement
I it really seemed like that's where we
were going from this downtrodden sulking
kind of human being to someone who finds
that you know like captivating rousing
Adventure within him once more
and he never finds it which I think is
what
undermines a lot of the excitement
behind the action scenes beside the fact
that they're loud and and wild that
they're actually not excited because
there's
there's no that there's that
swashbuckling spirit is not there
despite the fact that there's physical
things happening and I brought it up a
couple videos ago how there was a moment
that was so serious but hath our
audience started laughing really loud
and it is in that moment on the island
when Indiana Jones is like just let me
stay here I just want to die here
people just started cracking up
because when you think of if you I don't
really know I just kind of silly it's I
mean I I wasn't laughing but it is kind
of silly
because you think about it he just
starts off super sad and it just ends
super sad so he doesn't really learn
anything you know yes he does have the
moment with Miriam where it's like
ultimately he needs to be with his wife
and the movie doesn't quite strike this
Logan tone where we're going for the
realistic Humanity because this it's a
super unrealistic thing with this 80
year old guy seven-year-old however
Indiana is in the movie itself going
through this uh adventure and so they
they're trying to hit this like poignant
note at the end where yeah he just wants
to be with Marion in the end and then
it's a yeah we can move on we can grieve
together now or whatever I don't really
know exactly where the move is going by
the end of it but no it doesn't end off
on the note I think top gun Maverick is
the most
um apt thing to compare it to because
what
what I think this movie Far failed at
despite even for the people who like
this movie I mean for the people who
really like this film I feel like that a
lot of the ones are coming out we're
like no it's still a fun movie it's you
know whatever like there's the positive
rhetoric that surrounds it is that
ultimately yes there is something cool
and special just about seeing Indiana
Jones back but the movie he's in is not
all that special even if you like it
it's not really a special film
considerably
and that's the thing that movies really
need to be now in order to succeed like
top gun Maverick is a great example of a
legacy sequel coming out decades later
and for the most part it's a very
similar structure to the original Top
Gun however they made a movie that the
way they decided to execute it and you
can just see it in the trailers they did
something very special with this film
that warrants it being seen whereas a
lot of the marketing for this film they
don't even lean in on what some of the
more unique elements are for this movie
which is the setup for Indiana Jones
like you can't really show that in the
trailer which by the way someone did
point out to me that it's Indiana
Jones's story here the setup for him is
very similar to Han Solo and force
awakens and I never drew that parallel
but I'm like oh yeah that is very true
um but they they never really showed the
side of what would make this one special
and unique for the few things that did
make it unique because for the most part
it was just trying to
it was trying to do something it was
trying to capture what made the old one
special instead of being just uniquely
special if that makes sense so that's
what I was really missing for this movie
and I feel like that overall does kind
of translate there there could be
something to the fact too because like
even though Tom Cruise is 60 years old
such a big selling point is we know it's
Tom Cruise always doing the that we
see Tom Cruise doing whereas here some
people might not want to meet me a
little hesitant towards seeing Harrison
Ford who we know is extremely old you
know doing the action-adventure role and
putting on that like I'm I'm down with
seeing him and I think he I think I feel
like he actually gives a great
performance here but I can unders
there's a lot like you said earlier
there's a lot of mixed things to what
has led to this movie bombing ultimately
and and I feel like at the end of the
day if there's one thing I gotta narrow
it down to is that there's nothing
really that makes this a special Indiana
Jones movie it could be a fun good
decent installment
but not really that strong rousing
highlight you know does that make sense
yeah well he he even says in the trailer
like I've waited my whole life for this
and you when you watch the movie you're
like what are you talking about it's
kind of weird at my whole life to clear
my name so I could get back to my
apartment this is what I'm talking about
yeah how did he how did he clear get his
name clear to Berta so quickly look I
actually I did like the movie I will say
when I was watching out and it was when
I got home I started thinking on it more
I was like oh well it basically the
whole movie structure summed up my
thoughts of the entire franchise starts
off really really good amazing and then
as it goes on you know you start getting
these later Parts where everything still
sort of falls apart
um but I think a thing you touched upon
there with the whole Tom Cruise thing
you know Tom Cruise still has quite a
young following in a young audience the
demographics behind what the like who
went to watch this film The below 25 5
audience is almost completely
non-existent yeah and they didn't do
enough to sell it to to like the young
audience which is ultimately you know
where you get a lot of your money
um and Harrison Ford like we we love
them we'll never say a bad word about
the guy
um but normally in these situations like
in topco when you have a a you know a
more sort of an actor with a bit more
history you tend to cast younger actors
alongside him so like Miles Teller or
you know people who have a younger
following to really get them on board
now Phoebe while a bridge
she doesn't really have that massive
young following you know what I mean
like even shung Chi like I'll just get
Aquafina I don't know why I said Chung
Chi was an old guy but you know what I
mean when when they're casting these
side side characters they often get
people in who have the side characters
are basically there to help bring an
audience in and they're they're kind of
normally the comic relief and stuff and
share fleabag I actually enjoy it I'll
probably get slated but I enjoy it um in
England she's got quite a big following
but uh in the US I don't I don't feel
like I you know I'm not expecting
Americans to go out and watch stuff with
Phoebe while abridging if they're under
um so I think that impacted it obviously
I touched upon before the whole you know
the price of cinema tickets and I think
Hollywood have kind of killed one of
their big
um earners through through streaming and
basically pushing things out in this
45-day window now me and you we're all
there gentlemen you remember back in the
day yeah if a movie did badly in the
cinema what films would do is if it got
good word of mouth on VHS or dvd they'd
be able to recoup some of that money
back and there were so many films like
the thing
um where the the movies bombed in the
cinema but then once VHS came out a lot
they got lots of people picking that up
and the movie would recoup money now the
the physical media Market or I'm
considered a dinosaur because I still
buy Blu-rays and stuff but a lot of
people don't bother with that and
instead they'll just say well it's it's
going on Disney plus very soon I'll just
wait for that I'm not gonna spend you
know a hundred dollars taking my family
out to what could potentially just be a
disappointing movie because I've seen
the reviews from the Cannes Film
Festival where they all said it was
rubbish so I'm not going to take that
risk with my kids and I'll just wait
until it comes out
you know time's the type of people like
fair enough they don't want to like
spend that amount of money on two and a
half hours and watching Indiana Jones
when there is potential it could be bad
and unfortunately I've I've seen a lot
of films recently where
in the second weekend of them being out
they'll announce when they're coming out
on streaming and it'll be like three
weeks time so for example
um Creed and Evil Dead were both films
that I wanted to go see missed the first
weekend was gonna go the second weekend
and I remember going on Twitter for both
of these and it said the this film will
be released digitally in three weeks
time and I was like well you know I
could rush out and go to the cinema to
see them but I could just watch it at
home in three weeks time and that
completely killed my hype and I think
that Studios have they've destroyed the
physical media market and they've went
all in on streaming almost to the point
where they think it's going to be the
future but it's kind of killing the box
office returns because people will if
they're unsure on something they'll just
wait which is understandable because of
how expensive it is
um and if I if we weren't doing this for
a job I probably would have just waited
until this came out on Disney plus to be
honest
um I I don't see the necessity to go and
see it and seeing those early reviews
come out saying it was pretty meh or bad
um I just wouldn't have sold it on me
and you know we've been burned by Disney
before quite recently with with all
their
times that they've made bad movies with
Legacy characters
um and I just think yeah it's kind of
it's more than one thing here that's
causing these issues it's an entire
industry that's made fall After Fall
after fall and built themselves in a way
where
spending 300 million dollars on a movie
is not a it doesn't make sense
at all you you are never gonna break
even on this
um it and if you were it was going to
take a long long time so yeah I think
the reason for a bombing is just
widespread across a number of different
things of
slowly people just have built themselves
up to consume movies in a way where
you're not gonna go out and spend that
much money on a film if you're unsure on
it because of how quickly it's going to
come out
and the fact that it's probably going to
be included in something that you're
already paying for for example Netflix
or Disney plus where you don't even have
to pay for a VHS or a DVD anymore you
just it's all included well on Amazon
the acts the the accessibility on Amazon
too for VOD I know Universal they really
love the market for for digital VOD like
that that has been a game changer for
them as well like they they really
Embrace that
um so they don't delay at all and in now
on Amazon Prime you can see what like
the top 10 rented uh you know VOD
releases are of the week all the time
and that has been so it really is a
market because
you know a theater you got to really
split the costs for it for for the sales
of the movie whereas on video on demand
they get to keep all that money so yeah
they can they could be a lot more
lucrative and that was something that
um they really figured out during the
pandemic that's one thing Universal
really got to I think that was with
trolls World Tour where they realized
like wait a minute
we can make all kinds of money natural
resource or change the game for them
because I think that everything still
comes back to it being a ripple effect
of how Studios like I think what Warner
Brothers did
um at the time with with their same day
releases has really caused an
association for a lot of us even when
you think about when Disney plus was
doing you know the we're gonna release
Mulan and black widow the same day
they're out in the theaters and you
could just buy it at home instead and it
made us go oh okay then yeah I don't
need this there's there is a
subconscious Association I think a lot
of us have now uh you know transported
our minds to for these but as we're
looking ahead for July we have several
movies coming up that you sent me a list
of the opening weekend estimates and one
on here is making me so happy because
last time we talked you were talking
this movie Down Paul and it's looking to
be doing the best I am so happy for this
and you know why it's gonna do well
because it looks unique special within
all the men are finally willing to
embrace their feminine side for this
because if there's a man's man out there
it's Ryan Gosling so we got a list here
of opening week in Project actions what
is surprising me is just how well Barbie
is looking to be doing some of these one
in particular the main one that they're
competing with and what I love about
what's happening with certain
celebrities did you see those photos of
Tom Cruise and Christopher McCrory
they're like taking photos with ticket
stubs to go see Barbie and Oppenheimer
and then they got Martin you know I love
about that there was that rumor that Tom
Cruise is really angry that they were
all taking his screens yeah he was
calling up the cinema saying like I
don't want to get Barbie out of here I
don't want him in and then no he's on to
it but the guy's saving Cinema like
single-handedly Tom Cruise is out there
saving Cinema he's buying tickets to
everything I love the guy even though
even if he has these strange little
quirks that we'll not go into but I I
think the guy yeah yeah he's clearly has
a love he buys 4K Blu-rays so yeah got a
lot in common with him
um he just loves Cinema I mean fair
enough he's gonna kill you and your
whole family if you don't turn off
motion smoothing but other than that you
know he seems like he's really
supporting the films that they're
competing with and I feel like he wants
them all to do well and seeing the list
it all looks really good Greg I'm gonna
Pat I'm gonna take the mic away from
myself because I know I hug it so much
I'm gonna get you to read out the totals
thank you all right let's let's go here
let's go I'm gonna I'm gonna go from
most the highest earning expecting to
least Barbie 80 million to a hundred
million dollars Mission Impossible seven
this might be the highest opening
weekend for if it hits this number
um it's 90 million dollars next up
Oppenheimer this is not a great start
but I feel like they're depending on
legs for this versus opening weekend 40
million dollars after that we got
Disney's Haunted Mansion which looks
fine 25 million to 35 million dollars I
feel like it's going to come in less
than that people are certainly gonna
wait for Disney Plus on that one I can
feel it and Insidious The Red Door
um oh yeah I feel like this is not going
to perform well but it doesn't even make
a lot of money it's Insidious 20 million
to 29 million dollars which number here
stands we got to talk we have to talk
about Barbie for a second let's go
through them all from bottom to top so
Insidious the Red Duel yeah 20 to 29
million opening weekend prediction that
comes out this Friday
um
just about to say Horrors they don't
tend to spend a lot of money they're not
doing 300 million dollar budget horror
movies so I'll do it I'll do a quick
Google search for you there Greg and uh
we'll see what the budget is what you
mean it's 700 million dollars
um so yeah wolfman's worth a lot of
money now
so it was made on a budget of 10 million
dollars so if it hits this this weekend
yeah absolutely fine doubled its budget
already it's gonna it's made money for
the studio they haven't lost hundreds of
millions of dollars putting this up and
next in line we are going with haunted
mansion that looks that is not gonna
perform well I I don't think you'll do
well
Disney plus uh people are gonna wait now
you know what I was I forgot to bring up
in Indiana Jones back and slightly slot
it in here
Disney plus isn't doing well either
um apparently for this might be wrong
but from what I read on a report they're
losing subscribers and their their
Market values down actually 13 billion
dollars so not only are they costing all
their big movies they're also costing
the company because
it's just yeah kind of everyone's
waiting for Disney plus basically which
is fair enough you're paying for it that
they've thought this strategy is a good
idea to do
um so yeah
I'd be I think I might even do under
that you know might not be much but I
think it might do under now right now
I'm learning this right now A Haunted
Mansion is the most expensive Disney
live action film ever made apparently or
one of them not the most one one of the
most that no there's like the Pirates
movies are definitely more money but for
I think for a first starter because
there was a 2003 version but did you
have you Googled the budget have you
seen
157.8 million that is insane
157.8 million US Dollars
um yeah
I would be you know what I don't think
Disney have actually had a film for a
while that's made money
um light year bombed
Little Mermaids doing all right now
little mermaid's doing all right and
Elemental creeping up uh Elementals
picking up overseas
but it's not gonna make back the money
though no I was just being nice it's
gonna definitely fail yeah so I'm sure
I'm sure I read Mario cost 100 million
to make an elemental cost 200 million
100 million yeah
um so
what are they doing spending all those
money there must be a big
in quote
catering budget for this film you know
what I mean we're spending a lot on
catering for this film and it just so
the money just so happens to be going in
some exec's back pocket
um yeah that's gonna be another massive
bomb unfortunately for Disney sorry guys
uh we'll see 25 to 35 million opening
weekend on 157 million dollar budget
that is becoming lower than that I mean
that's that's not that's not a good luck
man and people will freaking wait for
that on Disney Plus for sure
um but Oppenheimer I'm surprised by the
production budget on it I thought it'd
be way more money uh to come how much is
it it's all it's only estimated to be a
hundred million dollars for the
production budget Nolan he is a g Nolan
I tell you he does it every time I'm
sure even with the Dark Knight the guy
came in about 50 million on the budget
and he just gave it back the studio I
was like we're balling and on
Interstellar yeah you know that
cornfield that they drive through he
actually that's real corn and what they
did is he bought a field had all the
corn planted for that scene they filmed
it and then he sold the field and made a
profit on it my boy Nolan he knows how
to make the dollars so yeah Oppenheimer
40 million you know half its budget
opening weekend roughly I actually think
it'll do slightly better not by much but
I think you know I could see it maybe
doing maybe maybe towards the 50. don't
know though uh I mean like from my
personal expand man the production
budget for dead reckoning so I I'll tell
you in a second but my my my personal
um sort of production budget for dinner
like holy that's a long one
um the for Oppenheimer
um I I had to get tickets because
there's very few screens out here in LA
or just actually in the United States
that are considered real IMAX uh meaning
the the actual size of it and the the
quality that it screens on and um
there's like a few theaters nearby but
the one that Christopher Nolan screens
at is in Universal CityWalk is an
adjacent Universal Studios so I like I
love to see movies at that IMAX I I love
to see them there I was not able to get
a ticket until like three weeks after
the movie releases it was just sold out
for a week so the the plan to you know
basically consume iMacs because a lot of
the time
iMac that a movie or even if a movie
shot with IMAX cameras they pretty much
leave after a week in a summer movie
season they're gone after like a week or
two
and oppenheimer's just got it booked for
so many weeks
and it looks to be paying off so I
really do think the word of mouth and
perhaps repeat viewing for cinephiles
because a lot of times when we're
talking about you know a movie's profit
and stuff we're always considering you
know what the general audience is going
to be because it's so important for
considering how much money a film is
going to make but Nolan has kind of a
unique case where he could really ride
cinephiles basically to you know actual
profit and I think Oppenheimer will be I
I have faith that I'll do and on top of
that too I think Universal they really
just want to keep Christopher Nolan like
them being able to snag him up after him
leaving Warner Brothers is a big get for
them so I think regardless they just
want this movie to have like a great
reception and and yada yada so yeah but
damn yeah
but please another thing you've said
there the iMac screens if they're that
booked out then that's a lot of money
because IMAX tickets obviously costs
almost double yeah exactly so you know
you might it might not show as many
times you know as many people might not
go see it but it's the same with 3D do
you remember when you know James
Cameron's knocking out of the park with
Avatar because it was in 3D and those
tickets were so much more expensive and
then every every film was like we're
doing 3D as well did you guys film it in
3D no we're just doing it post
conversion and you're paying the same
price and that's that is a reason why a
lot of um when you go back and look at
older movies when you're like it's
insane they made that much money but
it's because they also sold 3D tickets
um DC for some reason haven't really
done it but Marvel have always leaned
into it like I remember go you know
Avengers end game made a billion opening
weekend and I think a lot of people went
to see that in 3D which bumped up the
price 3D IMAX on top of it crazy
um so Nolan if he's got those iMacs a
premium seats all booked out then yeah I
think that could do well I think you
know up in Heimer I'm hoping I'm hoping
it as well but I you know I feel like
deep down Greg we're gonna be in three
weeks time we're gonna be back talking
about bombs again yeah and the first
point we're gonna bring up is why did
the release Barbie and Oppenheimer on
the same day
um but according to your your report you
know it's it's doing well which angers
me because it means I have to admit I'm
wrong and I'm so happy about it I really
hope it does this well
um I'd be so happy if it does well and
uh it's time he has the same production
budget as Oppenheimer that is oh really
that is insane to me yeah but I mean
it's it's a good low budget you know
what I mean 100 million dollar movie
like I was thinking today
so if Indiana Jones did cost 300 million
dollars like which it pretty much did
why why is that a better idea than
someone just going to lucasfilm and
going look got these three good scripts
the new properties the new IPS instead
of just completely running everything we
have into the ground why not just green
light these three movies we put them
into production one of them might turn
out to be a John Wick where it makes
money and we could build a massive
franchise off it why not do these three
100 million dollar scripts instead of
one Indiana Jones film and yeah I was
just thinking about that today just
doesn't make sense I only spent that
much money
um but yeah back to back to Bobby so 80
to 100 million
um so yeah
if if that turns out to be true you know
I hope five years from now I come out
with an opinion in the first commenters
yeah but you said Bobby would bomb you
idiot so uh yeah you know what I'd be
happy to be proven wrong I hope because
it seems like a nice fun positive movie
you know what I mean if it does if it
does well then yeah good good on you
guys and you're competing with
Christopher Nolan as well and he's my
one of my heroes so if you beat the guy
then uh all props to Bob's and I might
even start buying Barbie Funko Pops in
line and pretend I was a fan the entire
time I actually got a Ryan Gosling Ken
doll
actual one and some are amazing but I
don't want to stand
um then we got dead reckoning part one
this is crazy because you know you
brought up the whole thing about
um Tom Cruise maybe being like pissed
off and trying to like you IMAX
reconsider letting us stay here uh
longer that's not fair uh but their
their production budget is significantly
higher than Oppenheimer it is
290 million dollars
Mission Impossible seven I was like oh
that's a great number uh 90 million but
damn like if you do the comparison here
it's like oppenheimer's more likely to
recoup that money back because dead
reckoning part one they also they're
throwing down for marketing on this film
so I've just looked online there and
dead so dead reckonings 290 million US
dollars
uh the last one Mission Impossible
Fallout cost 178 million so this is a
112 million more budget than
uh the last movie now to be fair they
did film during covid because we all
heard Tom Cruise on on set his recording
talked about stuff
um so to be fair to Indiana Jones as
well that had that going for it too
where they had to keep stopping and
starting production just because of the
whole pandemic situation
um but 112 million dollar more I are you
allowed to say anything or am I gonna
get you in trouble ah I know I I can I
can say it looks expensive
okay so can you say you've seen it yeah
I haven't seen it have you yeah I've
done my social media reaction so I can
say I've seen it okay so I like it
um yeah did did you think it it looks
the money
I
I need to watch it on IMAX to really
know for sure
um but yeah I would say so and I think
there's
a little more visual of I mean that
practical costs a lot of money
obviously like if you watch the behind
the scenes of just him doing the
motorcycle stunt have you have you seen
it Paul
they have to spend millions of dollars
just to just to train him to do the stun
and then to build a whole ramp and get
the location just to do that one like
what lasts a few seconds in the movie
It's So short-lived in the movie
um yeah it's it's remarkably short but
that alone Cinema lives forever
the scene is so short it's
that it's it's not like the Dubai scene
or him on the plane where it's like a
full scene you're like oh he's off he's
off the cliff now that's yeah that's the
end of it right there it's done
um but yeah it's just that alone and
like they wanted to blow up a real train
but then that whole train sequence you
could tell there's a lot of like visual
effects helping back it it is expensive
like yeah it looks expensive and also
the cast is bigger this time around too
you know you got like a lot of people
here we're all obviously probably won't
pay you know a little increase in pay as
well so and and it's Tom Cruise you know
so who usually he usually takes a
smaller upfront fee for a salary so that
way he can make more money on the back
end because he's he's a producer of all
those movies so you usually that's how I
made like a ton of money off of top
gun Maverick is because he he usually
takes the back end points of a film
yeah well that'll be why won't it I mean
is it he's a producer of these films too
yeah so uh you know I hope he does well
our Tom he's putting his life on the
line every film
yeah um but that budget's crazy and
there is one scene
there is one scene it is so funny
because someone said it out loud in the
screening I went to there's one scene in
this film
where and I think it they might have
done it because a lot of this movie has
this strange thing about
Ethan hunted and women I mean I feel
like it's too much to say but it's like
women love Ethan Hunt and there's this
one particular scene where
I was watching it and I was like wow did
they DH Tom Cruise and it's not like a
flashback I was watching the scene where
he just looks so de-aged and then
someone a few seats down for me just
says out loud did they DH you he just
says it right out loud in the screen and
I think they de-aged him for this one
particular scene which is pretty fun
until the budget went yeah but funny for
a film about AI
um about AI is the enemy but I'm I'm
pretty confident they dhed him in in
this like one random scene in the film
uh it's because of what they're talking
about here the camera's like super close
up on his face you might notice it
can you say it about AI I feel like I
didn't know that you didn't know that no
I had no idea so can you say it's d8 I'm
just gonna go through everything you
just said are you allowed to say it's DH
are you Lotus so you've seen it it's I'm
just looking online it looks like yeah
I'm looking online and just reading
things about Hayley Atwell apparently at
school she got called Hayley fatwell oh
so I bet she's laughing now yeah hello
suckers at home watching her on the big
screen she's 295 mil phenomenal as she
is easily the the standout performer
like uh yeah she's she is she's Brill
she is brilliant in the movie oh yeah it
is you know what I hope they do
help them make a Captain Carter movie
that's what I'm talking about Captain
I'll wear Captain cutter Merchant
people know that I'd do that in my real
life I'm a loser
um
that sounds really good
um so what is the next topic oh yeah
dude okay change the tone we always save
the change of tone one for the last one
because I think like you know there's
things to talk about but you and I are
both on the same page about this which
is
we kind of have to wait you know and
people form such strong opinions about
this right away uh which obvious under
such a sensitive subject so it's
understandable that people will form
strong opinions about it uh but yeah
there's the Jonathan Majors updates you
know the the last time we talked uh it
was about how
he had uh his the his defense lawyer did
talk to The Insider and then apparently
they revealed a lot of what they have in
their defense as evidence and there
seemed to be a lot to support that the
thing he got arrested for he was looks
like there's a lot of support that he
actually could be innocent in this and
then since that time a couple of other
things have happened uh there's this
Rolling Stones article that came out
that was not specifically about the case
but about a lot of allegations with his
past with former girlfriends and
experiences that people had working with
him on set about his behaviors and some
stuff about emotional in one case being
a case of physical abuse and all
allegations everything's an allegation
it's important innocent until proven
guilty that's really important to State
and then there was this thing about uh
let me I want to make sure I just say
this properly because it was like oh
Jonathan Major's ex-girlfriend the one
Grace Jabari the one who with the trials
in relation to they're like she's been
arrested she has actually not been
arrested uh they found the NYPD has
found probable cause to arrest her on
suspicion of a third degree assault
however she has not been arrested so a
lot of things are ongoing and then the
trial still hasn't been set yet
and it's really important that while
this
is playing out like this is going to be
a really big popular thing here and and
I think a lot of times everyone becomes
very reactionary towards information
that comes out which is like told you he
was innocent no told you he was guilty
and it's like let's just wait like let's
just wait the part that sounds
because like everything here
it's it can be so muddy to talk about
right like when I when I hear about like
I read the Rolling Stones article when
it first came out and it's specifically
in relation to the stuff about him being
like emotionally abusive in the past I'm
like okay but
not to say that anything anything along
those lines is okay it's it's a the
question is though like how long ago was
it and has he grown as an individual to
the point like did he
there are cases where a lot of us have
had terrible relationships that have
been emotionally abusive in the past I'm
talking just about the emotional abuse
Department I'm talking about the
physical altercation one but the
emotional abusive side of have people
had the chance to to change as a human
being as an individual and are they
still that person today you know and
that a lot of that seems like such a
private matter as well you know and it's
like it could be such a gray subject
like how what is the degree of how bad
it is and instead of you could just
easily label something as as an
emotional and I'm sure I'm sure
emotional abuse could be a real thing
that took place but what was the degree
of it of
forgivability to non-forgivability here
and
yeah you know like it's the the sad part
is is like depending on how severe those
situations are and if he did not pay any
retributions for those past things all
that's really going to matter in this
case though it what it seems like
currently like I said we just have so
much information that we need to unfold
what it seems like currently happening
with this case is all about the
situation with the arrest with his
ex-girlfriend Grace Jabari and
if he's proven innocent there
what sucks is is like if any of these
past things he does deserves some type
of punishment for if he does deserve
punishment for it
they're probably not going to receive
those those victims who receive
retribution for it because all people
are going to think about is the one case
and it's that kind of terrible situation
where he could be proven innocent in
this very specific one so it could
disregard anything that really did
happen prior if anything really did
happen prior but we don't know we just
don't we just don't know so much we
don't know and it's like there's a
billion different speculation directions
you could go down but at this point it's
all just a lot of it really is like
little bits that we have yet it's like
commenting on the Johnny Depp trial was
different because we were literally
watching the trial there were hours and
hours and hours of the trial and here
we're just getting
little reports here or there you know so
I think yeah and I don't think this is
going to be one that is televised the
way how like Johnny Depp's trial was
televised
so it's important that we we just wait
you know because there's a billion
different directions this can go down of
uh of whether or not he deserves to be
condemned or not condemned and then to
go through his past as well of because
you know people talk about like him on
set he was is apparently like really bad
on set and the other people are going
well no he's just method acting and it's
like okay but what's the line there like
every Everything is a conversation at
this point and not a condemnation yet
you know like you just kind of yeah so
wait we gotta wait
I think my issue with everything is that
I personally believe that the apologies
should be as loud as the accusations and
it's never the case on social media so I
think you know we have seen times in the
past before where someone's been accused
of doing something everyone's jumped on
them there's been a massive pylon
canceled you know lots their jobs and so
on and so forth now if they get if it
hits a point where they get Vindicated
the apologies on anywhere near that loud
no one's coming out apologizing on mass
you know what I mean there's very few
things so I think in in cases like that
it's important to just wait until all
the facts are right because reports can
be twisted
um either way and you know you might you
might jump on the wrong person for some
reason or you know you might not you
know they might be proven to be guilty
and so on there's lots of ways that
these things can go and I think it's
important to just have straight and wait
for the whole
situation to come out now we've seen
this week has been the perfect example
of why it's totally fine to just not
jump on every single piece of media
because at a point where Jonathan Majors
everyone was saying oh well look he's
innocent he's innocent and then
literally the next day
the the same people were doing a 180
because of that Rolling Stones article
instead of thinking look I've seen two
different things here that have made me
change my mind maybe I should just hold
off and wait until everything's out and
instead of doing that they're just
reacting to whatever piece comes out
even if they're complete Polar Opposites
to each other they're just saying no I
believe this no no I believe that no
and it's a very strange situation
um with the case of the Rolling Stones
thing what it looked like to me was
it was almost done as a sort of backfire
for him getting to the point where he
had evidence proving that he was
innocent
um and it just dropped my really weird
time the timing is so questionable yeah
it's like they win it was literally like
oh it's hot right now drop it you know
yeah it was literally like
I've here's my evidence showing that you
know the the claims may be fabricated
everyone's like all right okay and then
it's like oh well but what about this
from 10 years ago that we dug up the the
three people that used to know and work
with they've said this and so on and so
forth
um so I kind of felt like they just kind
of pulled that out of out of thin air
um I'm a bit conscious that my camera
keeps going out of focus so sorry guys
if you I don't think you're watching
this still are you
um but yeah Jonathan major is kind of
it felt like he hit a point where he he
almost had Vindication and then the
media kind of needed to spin it to the
point where it was like well no we
haven't we've still got a story to run
on you and I'm just kind of hitting
hitting a point now with things where
I'm happy to wait and see what the
outcome is rather than just
saying that oh this is definitely the
case this week and then the next week
saying the exact opposite you know these
are people it's not like Barbie where I
say I don't think Bobby's gonna do well
and it does well you know these are
people's lives and careers that people
are basically turning into entertainment
so they can jump on them on social media
and no matter what happens in this
situation there's not really a winner
because let's say Jonathan Mages is
innocent
the the crappies had to go through the
last couple of months is absolutely
terrible I mean the guy was on top of
the world he had Creed and Ant-Man two
number one films back to back and then
this brought it all down now that's even
if he gets seen as innocent
like that is a horrendous thing to go
through now if he's guilty then
obviously the victim they've got
everything about their life
um exposed it's now out there in public
domain unfortunately the way people's
minds work is that you know Monica
Lewinsky if ever anyone talks about her
that their mind goes to the whole thing
with Bill Clinton first because that's
what she's famous for this unfortunately
is what this This Woman's going to be
famous for and
it's going to constantly get brought up
for the rest of her life and
it's not real any real winners in this
situation where
someone's gonna lose and it's going to
be devastating to them
um and
I just think people should show a bit
more kind of restraint when dealing with
this stuff and not what you know wait
until they know the full story because
no one does you know nothing's been
fully presented in court or publicly yet
there's been certain things that have
been given to TMZ and but beyond that
that there's nothing that I feel like we
will help by saying oh well yes they're
definitely guilty or yes they're
definitely innocent and you know people
they are it's fair enough that people
are going to report on this because it's
in the public domain but I personally
would say
just be careful what you say because you
know if if you don't know all the facts
it's totally fine to just keep your
mouth closed there's certain things that
you can you can say all the time like
Bobby's gonna bomb and stuff like that
but when it when it's this level of
serious I think it's totally fine to not
give your opinion on it and just say
what you want
um like even when we talked about it
last week we went solely at it from the
perspective of what should Marvel do
with their main actor that they built
this entire next phase around it wasn't
a case of like well I've weighed up the
evidence that I read on someone's Tick
Tock and Reddit and stuff like that
we've always kind of tried to come from
it
sort of like a business point of view
rather than
condemning or saying oh well I don't
think this story adds up you know what I
mean so it's uh and and that is the case
as well like there's so much conflicting
evidence at this point that it's totally
fine to let the lawyers and the judge do
their job and decide in this scenario
and just the the ugliness will
follow him around forever
um yeah even if he is even in this
specific case with Grace Jabar if he's
found innocent there's so much else that
has now come out that are allegations
against him that just completely follow
with him like a like a dark looming
Shadow now and it's so much harder to
separate that when you're in
when you're an actor I think versus if
you're like a filmmaker I think it's how
like Mel Gibson managed to still work
because he's mainly a filmmaker right
um and more than more than like he does
a lot of these like low budget movies
now but like the thing that really
allowed him to keep bouncing back was
like yeah I got Apocalypto and hacksaw
Ridge like these like highly regarded
films that he directed
um but when you're an actor like that
really that really follows you around
way worse there's a time I mean before
social media and all that like
you know like you think about like what
Sean Penn has done in the past like some
Terror like he's one actor that comes to
mind there's some actors who've done
some like terrible things but it was
before the day and age of social media
even it was a lot easier to just forget
about it and now it's so much harder to
forget about it because even for like
Johnny Depp like
even though Dean innocent got a big fan
base it's you
there used to be a time where like
Johnny Depp you just saw the character
that he would play now it's they're so
aware of Johnny Depp now in his personal
life and all these things whenever he
pops up anywhere now
um so yeah just kind of follow Josh
Brolin both
um MCU phase villains have have been um
have had their own controversy surround
like in the same situation
um but you can see how and I'm I know
there's there's things like race
involved as well
um we we shouldn't Overlook stuff like
that and there's lots of different
factors going into this case and
sometimes you know like I'll I'll talk
about it privately with people and
they'll say
um well look what happened in this case
that all got proven to be wrong so see
you can't believe what this person says
um and every case is different as well
it's not like this happened on this case
so it must be true on this case sort of
thing you know every single case is
different there's lots of different
factors going on in if everyone can just
chill and I know it's the internet I
know it's detached from me real life so
there's not you know as many
consequences for jumping on this stuff
but just think about you know the people
involved in it and
yeah how bad it looks no you know you
know gonna think about it no you're not
I didn't think you were so yeah that's
the that's the episode is it I've Just
Seen uh from Daniel rpk I get the house
of hawkness Evan Peters is reprising his
role as Ralph boner so the thing I
expected we missed the big topic to
really break down today
the disappointment
well he's got to be Quicksilver of his
back surely they can't Ralph boner us
again I mean he could just be Ralph
boner
yep true yeah yeah do not think
people would be annoyed
do not think the MCU needs to win people
back around
it's like me when I make an offensive
joke to my wife I
instead of apologizing I go let me just
keep doubling down on this joke in hopes
that she eventually comes around and
starts laughing
and she never does and that's what I
think they're gonna do with Ralph
they're gonna try to just make it work
um more like they made Trevor Slattery
work he's apparently coming back a third
time so okay
yeah you know what's annoying that
Quicksilver had the best Speedster scene
of all time and nothing's tough to ever
since that was the first one as well I
don't know man saving babies in a
microwave might be might be the one
uh it might be the one yeah apparently
that film's like eighth place at the box
office now and across the spider versus
taking over it again they're taking yeah
moving it from theaters
yeah
I know well I am legit it's so funny
yeah I am legitimately worried about the
state of Hollywood right now oh it's
awful and just how badly things are
going even without the strikes these box
office says they don't look good for the
future and then you've got the strikes
on top
Disney are pretty much tanked every
single franchise they've got you know
Marvel's sort of teetering on but even
the secret Invasion viewership it
couldn't even break a million for the
first episode which is absolutely crazy
you think like a secret Invasion
adaptation for how big that comic was
starring Samuel L Jackson
uh yeah it's it's a shame and
everything's kind of just going down the
pan but you know it might lead to some
good things in the future we we gotta I
know this podcasts be negative every
single week except for maybe the first
week when we talked about across the
spider verse but you you know this might
lead to some good stuff where Hollywood
decide to think you know what we're
losing money either way let's get
creative with it and try and build new
franchises and things that people are
going to enjoy 50 years from now instead
of ruining things from 50 years ago so
hopeful message to end on there guys
Greg would you like to have the final
say I can't wait for the Barbie Mattel
Cinematic Universe Paul
20 years from now I'm excited for it and
while you're still at the pub with your
friends bitching about how your wife
wants to go take your two sons to go
watch Barbie
you know what yeah I'm sure Hollywood's
thinking right we've tanked everything
right now but we're having tagged anime
yet let's get on it let's get on thanks
sir thanks for sticking with us guys
it's crazy seeing the viewership on this
podcast sometimes 41
000 on the last podcast uh crazy that
there's that many listeners for us
talking nonsense so this this week will
probably be a drop off but we want to
thank you for sticking with us again
um hopefully next week we're back with a
bit more positivity there's no only
Insidious coming out this week so we
haven't got anything to about next
week but you know it's a a week's a long
time in Hollywood and uh yeah we'll get
back to you next week so make sure if
you haven't that you subscribe to us on
Spotify Apple podcasts Amazon podcasts
and YouTube whatever you like to listen
to us on we're gonna be there for you
every single Tuesday same time same bat
Channel I'm out Greg are you out as well
I'm out I'm out too I'm gonna stop
recording now